el temido callejón de la muerte
aquí Noé recibió seis impactos de bala
de manos de La Pandilla barrio 18 en
entró acá con el régimen de excepción
impuesto hace un año por el presidente
nayib bukele los ciudadanos de este
suburbio de San Salvador hoy se siente
más seguros según las encuestas esta
medida es apoyada por un 80% de la
población
con la seguridad
ha puesto y el régimen que hay estamos
felices
pero Osvaldo no está feliz su esposa
Claudia fue detenida hace 11 meses y su
caso se suma a las 5000 denuncias de
capturas injustificadas bajo este
régimen pero esa es la lucha por querer
demostrar ante el juez con los arraigos
pues la inocencia y la injusticia que
están cometiendo en el caso de ella pero
ante los medios de comunicación
nacionales y ante los informes del
gobierno ya ahí aparece como una
terrorista para la fundación de estudios
para la aplicación del derecho la
percepción de seguridad en el régimen es
un Espejismo tras el que se oculta la
institucionalización de violaciones a
derechos humanos es un pretexto para
reprimir no para combatir la
delincuencia Aquí hay una ausencia total
de una política criminal
el gobierno adjudica la reducción de
homicidios a la detención de más de 66
mil personas este último año pero las
madres que demandan la liberación de sus
hijos en las calles no están de acuerdo
con los procesos
ya es
tiempo de que alguien sepa que estamos
sufriendo según cifras del gobierno la
medida ha sido un logro porque la tasa
de homicidios en 12 meses es 3,6 muertes
por cada 100.000 habitantes mientras que
en 2015 era de 103 ahora la excepción de
garantía Es una constante y la
preocupación de la familia de las
familias salvadoreñas es que buenos y
malos están siendo detenidos sin
distinción